um I've come back not for you but for
the staff they deserve better
we're losing on average 15 to $20,000 a
month and we are short but you have a
serious hobby of sort of an art
collector and I mean you could open a
museum how many pieces you have enough
oh my god
hundreds what we're talking about
everything collectively all those
beautiful old paintings the expensive
stuff at a suitable auction maybe
$300,000 soon $2,000 and that would
supplement you for the next 12 months 18
months yes that would certainly get us
through that would get us through two
years I'm right listen I want you to see
yeah I need to come with me please
but there's one thing we need right now
is an injection of funds Wow Robert no
man alive needs this much stuff walking
in it was shocking
now van T's oil paintings silverware
does it not
I mean frustrate you that we're sat with
all this and yet we can't pay our staff
properly
there's someone I'd like you to meet
she's the head auctioneer at Bonhams in
Boston
hey good morning good morning Gordon
nice to see Gordon great to see
otherwise thank you so much for coming
and we're in the [ __ ] basically and this
stuff needs to go we need to raise as
much money as possible so what's the
best price we can get for this stuff
[Music]
what you have here doesn't read as a
collection to me it's kind of an
accumulation a lot of copies of things
or if they are of the period that
they're supposed to be there's some
condition issues
[Music]
I would say about 25,000 say that good
25,000 $25,000 all this all this amy's
opinion on our are things was shocking
and I can't really believe that on the
painting the painting is a copy and not
a good one I'm afraid how much that what
I can't imagine what someone would pay
for it it's really very low value Wow
Robert I thought you said it was
expensive 18th century
well it's dated and dated 17 it is but
it's not actually of that period at all
I'm sorry did you know that was a copy I
did not know that that was a company
lots of copies reproductions
reproductions we're hoping in the
ballpark of three to four hundred
thousand 25 grand for everything yeah
that won't even get us through the next
five weeks even all this amazing
silverware I put $100 on everything on
this table hundred dollars what about
this first period this Sheffield yeah
its plate what about this one hundred
and seventy-five bucks
those are Volkl kendo sticks they just
don't bring very much at auction I'm
afraid is this the current election that
you'd be willing to sell it bottoms will
you take the whole lot no we wouldn't
Wow
we would have to say no we're floating
as if we've got this asset full of three
or four hundred thousand dollars worth
of antiques we haven't and we distracted
with the bits of crap in here it was a
wake-up call thank you that's just my
pleasure thank you it means that we
don't have the backup that we thought we
had we've paid more money for [ __ ]
storage than they're worth than they're
worth does that not bring it home a
little bit earlier that you need to be
an innkeeper not a part-time antiques
dealer because you fooled me you give me
the turn I thought wow this guy's you've
got serious cash to burn but right now
we're even
further in the [ __ ] than I thought we
were so the pressure intensifies